cameraman Bob Poole searches for an
elusive group of migrating desert
elephants but the Sahara is about to
throw him a gigantic bombshell we knew
that eventually there would be a dust
storm or what there they call a temp at
the day that the thing came I felt
something funny I just I kept saying hey
we content that
this thing is going really really fast
yeah we are you're gonna we're going to
stick this out
it's across the entire horizon
and it was just wind you know with
driving sand we just kept em rolling
the thing ran over is like a freight
train
closer closer
how
it seems like they've been transported
to Mars
for four hours sand blocks episode
but it's like it's like jumping into a
giant sand blaster oh my god it's
getting lighter look at this but man oh
man I tell you John it really this is
this goes down as the wildest thing I
have ever seen in my life honestly
can you believe